madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir le
concorde spécial du président de la
république se pose en ce moment même sur
l'aéroport de brasilia
le chef de l'état commence ainsi une
visite officielle qui durera jusqu'à
samedi
une importante délégation accompagne
messieurs giscard d'estaing qui aura
deux entretiens avec le numéro un
brésilien le général geisel nous aurons
l'occasion de reparler de cette arrivée
dans quelques minutes vers 8h 18h 11 ans
les environs notre rond patrick poivre
d'arvor et noël copains qui suivent pour
nous ce voyage du chef de l'état au
brésil
auparavant l'actualité nous conduit
aujourd'hui à rome à nouveau et à
beyrouth à nouveau rome tout d'abord où
les obsèques du pape jean paul 1er ont
été célébrées cet après midi il ne pleut
pas pas encore quand commence à 16
heures précises les obsèques du pape
porté par les douces et diary le
cercueil de cyprès orné d'une simple
croix des bennes sera posée à même le
sol devant l'autel au premier rang la
famille de l'ancien archevêque de venise
son frère et puis les personnalités le
président de la république italienne
le premier ministre espagnol c'est le
ministre de l'intérieur christian bonnet
qui représente la france
le président jimmy carter en vrille et
sa mère madame liliane carter le doyen
du sacré collège cardinal carlo
gonfalonier riz 85 ans célèbre la messe
c'est lui également qui prononcera
l'homélie
terminaux doué mais personne ne pouvait
pas se dit au fond n'est vrai j'ai les
bras tant inc reste à pyatt ça sans
titre alors que elle n'a célébrions les
obsèques de paul 6 sur cette même place
personnalités pensée sera très brève
trouvé que jean paul 1er à 16h30 une
demi heure après le début de la
cérémonie commence à pleuvoir la place
saint-pierre se transforme en une
immense forêt de parapluies pour
protéger le cardinal gonfalone hier et
on est obligé d'apporter aux couleurs du
vatican
il est très précisément 16h30 les
parapluies ce niveau 16h45
il pleut des cordes sur ron et puis à 17
heures au moment où 200 prêtres vont
distribuer la communion à la foule la
pluie s'arrête juste au moment du baiser
de paix de très nombreux fidèles comme
unis très très nombreux trop nombreux
eux mêmes il n'y aura pas assez de ce
type pour tout le monde
ensuite ce sera l'absoute et l'hommage
des églises d'orient comme pour les
funérailles de paul 6 le 12 août dernier
la foule applaudira au départ du
cercueil dans dix jours
il faudra élire le 265e successeur de
saint pierre mais route
meurtri beyrouth sous les bombes
aujourd'hui encore en dépit des
protestations internationales l'armée
syrienne a poursuivi le pilonnage des
quartiers chrétiens de la capitale
libanaise beyrouth est coupé du reste du
monde le seul poumon de cette capitale
c'est son aéroport
un poumon asphyxier les candidats au
départ sont bien trop nombreux les
premières images de la capitale du liban
bombardé viennent de nous parvenir
regardons les ensembles
cette fumée noire qui flotte sur la
ville c'est le spectacle qui s'offre
chaque matin aux habitants de beyrouth
beyrouth où il tombe est aux premières
heures de la matinée un obus toutes les
secondes
la capitale libanaise est toujours
isolée du monde les communications
téléphoniques qui avait été rétabli pour
quelques heures sont à nouveau coupée de
même que l'eau et l'électricité dans
beyrouth est les incendies s'allument
les uns après les autres et de grands
nuages de fumée noire provenant des
réservoirs de pétrole en flammes étaient
visibles depuis la frontière israélienne
selon la radio conservatrice les
bombardements longtemps limité à l'est
de la ville ce temps étendu aujourd'hui
à la banlieue nord est jusque dans la
montagne
mais c'est au tour des pans de la
quarantaine qui contrôlent l'accès au
quartier d'achrafieh places fortes des
milices conservatrice que le plus gros
des combats se déroulent
les premiers bilans sont impressionnants
toujours selon la radio phalangistes les
combats de lundi et mardi
aurais tu es le seul fait 500 morts et
blessés presque tous des civils
en effet les bombardement se poursuit
visant essentiellement la population
civile des quartiers chrétiens de
beyrouth pourtant depuis plusieurs jours
la communauté internationale s'émeut du
génocide ainsi perpétré comme elles
s'étaient émus et à juste titre en son
temps du génocide du camp de tahar el
zaatar sur le plan politique on le sait
depuis zir la france tente de faire
cesser les combats
le conseil des ministres ce matin a
évoqué la situation au liban le
président de la république a donné sa
position il y a des propositions pour
que l'on puisse obtenir rapidement un
cessez le feu sur place ces propositions
est élaboré en liaison avec le président
sarkis le président libanais à qui le
président giscard d'estaing a téléphoné
hier et elle vise à séparer les
combattants sur le terrain c'est à dire
d'une part à regrouper les forces
syriennes et d'autre part a donné aux
forces régulières libanaise qui existe
une responsabilité dans la surveillance
de l'ordre à beyrouth même et dans un
deuxième temps la négociation dans un
deuxième temps des négociations avec
toutes les parties concernées
c'est-à-dire essentiellement les
musulmans et les chrétiens au liban pour
arriver un véritable pacte national qui
permettrait à ce pays de retrouver sa
sécurité sa souveraineté et d'assurer
son indépendance
reste à savoir quelles sont les forces
en présence côté libanais le compte est
vite fait l'armée libanaise n'existe
pratiquement plus sinon sur le papier
elle s'est dissoute au fil des de la
guerre civile reste d'une part les
palestiniens et d'autre part les milices
chrétiennes et en face de ces milices
l'armée syrienne l'une des plus
puissantes du proche orient
elle peut mettre par exemple en ligne
plus de chars de combat que l'armée
française actuellement
l'armée syrienne en campagne ou plutôt
la force arabe de dissuasion puisque
c'est son appellation officielle mais en
fait personne ne s'y trompe lui la fad
est bel et bien une armée syrienne
ils sont aujourd'hui trente mille au
liban qui avait été appelé pour remettre
de l'ordre dans ce pays déchiré par la
guerre civile
un chiffre qui peut être doublée en
quelques heures sur simple décision du
président assad
partout ce sont des chars en position ce
sont des sentinelles derrière des sacs
de sable ce sont des barrages à tous les
points stratégiques de la capitale
libanaise en principe le mandat de
l'afad expire le 26 octobre
et c'est le conseil des ministres de la
ligue arabe qui décidera si oui ou non
les syriens doivent rester au liban et
pourtant la syrie dans cette affaire
reste jusqu'à présent muette le
président hafez el-assad après avoir
donné l'ordre à ses soldats de pilonner
de matraquer les quartiers chrétiens de
beyrouth s'est envolé pour berlin est
une escale avant un séjour à moscou pour
la première fois un représentant syrien
en occident a cependant accepté de
répondre aux questions des journalistes
l'ambassadeur de syrie à paris ainsi
reçu aujourd'hui une équipe d'antenne
des phalangistes et
pjanic on essaie de créer une situation
au liban une flambée de violence de
façon à préoccuper la syrie à la
paralyser et à la neutraliser un tout en
empêchant de jouer son rôle au sein du
dpi de fermeté pour contrecarrer la cua
séparer entrepris en ces dates à camp
david
oui mais au delà de la flambée de
violence même si l'ambassadeur on incite
quand même un massacre généralisé il
semble et derrière les canons votre
armée l'armée syrienne mais
permettez-moi de ne le titre mise au
point ce qu'on appelle massacre
entreprises paraissait rien ce n'est pas
un massacre démence et riposte aux tirs
massifs des phalangistes qui cherche à
faire ressortir la riposte des liens
comme si c'était des massacres des
chrétiens les phalangistes n'opposons
pas des chrétiens ce sont eux qui en
déclin dépensiers les tirs et malgré le
respect du cessez le feu de la part des
forces arabes dissuasion des troupes
syriennes
il s'acharne un peu serré les dents
leurs tirs quel est votre but quel est
votre plan concrètement au liban notre
but au liban au liban c'est de rétablir
l'ordre
c'est 2 et d'aidé motorisée rien si l'on
prend dans un ordre syrien un an un
ordre au profit de la légitimité de
président de la république d'aider le
liban à voir ces administrations propre
à voir son armée à avoir à pouvoir
établir un liban souverain qui arrêtent
hérin réintégrer ces territoires et qui
fit qui vit paisiblement dans lequel les
confessions des verts confiance entre
eux vivent dans un même pays comme mais
elle était auparavant il n'y a pas le
grand rêve de la syrie le grand rêve
annexionnistes la jordanie le grand
croissant vers la syrie liban le ce sont
de purs mensonges quand déclenché pour
présenter la série comme si c'était un
pays occupant la politique française le
gouvernement défend sa politique
aujourd'hui devant l'assemblée nationale
le parti socialiste vous le savez a
déposé une motion de censure le débat a
débuté cet après midi et c'est monsieur
mitterrand qui le premier a pris la
parole pour notre censure s'adressent à
d'autres qu'à vous même vous exécuter
une politique voulzy remplissez un grand
rôle en raison de votre personne et de
ses capacités mais vous êtes fidèle à la
philosophie politique économique y est
vôtre et qui nous paraît aller en contre
sens des nécessités exigé par la fin de
ce siècle
mais au delà de vous énumérons
rappellerait la politique du chef de
l'état dont vous êtes ici le terme ne
présente rien d'insolent le commis comme
on dit les grands commis de l'état
vous exécutez une politique qui vient
d'ailleurs et cette politique si je
voulais la résumer d'un mot je dirais la
politique des coups pour rien du plateau
le premier ministre a bien sûr répondu
immédiatement pour au premier secrétaire
du parti socialiste la politique du
gouvernement je les assume entièrement a
dit monsieur raymond barre si sur
quelques points il existait un désaccord
entre le président de la république et
moi raymond barre je ne resterai pas une
minute de plus à assumer mes fonctions
et puis le premier ministre s'est
adressé directement à françois
mitterrand
toutes les fois qu'il me laisse quelques
jours à vivre ou qu'ils annoncent que le
gouvernement est condamné à disparaître
ils assurent ma longévité et celle du
gouvernement et bien
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui encore je me
suis dit que l'issue fatale n'était pas
pour demain
on l'a fait d'ailleurs observé très
justement on voit mal au cas où cette
motion serait votée quelle majorité
cohérente et stable pouvait se dégager
des formations de l'opposition et
socialistes et communistes les radicaux
de gauche se disent beaucoup de choses
mais ils ne se le dise pas avec des
fleurs
voilà pour la principale intervention
donc de la journée dans ce débat sur la
motion de censure à débat daniel brême
vous êtes en direct avec nous qui
semblait 10 ont manqué un peu
d'enthousiasmé
un petit coup de téléphone nous avons
peut-être un petit problème via rail de
coke
si voilà daniel web apparaît sur notre
écran laniel je disais que ce débat
semblait disons aux observateurs manqué
un tout petit peu d'enthousiasmé
vous avez raison le coeur n'y était
vraiment pas nous avons assisté une
sorte d'opération vérité avec tout ce
que là cela comporte de petites phrases
venimeuses mais malgré cela il n'y avait
pas de passion alors il y avait à cela
trois raisons la première c'est que les
députés sont tous préoccupés par le
problème de l'emploi
la seconde c'est que ils ont redit ce
qu'il répète depuis la campagne
électorale et enfin la troisième comme
l'a dit monsieur beurre il s'agit d'un
acte gratuit puisque tout le monde sait
que la censure ne sera pas votée alors
me direz vous il y avait tout de même
sans doute des faits saillants et bien
on attendait des interventions tout de
même assez remarquée dans le port ce
premier grand débat de la session
d'automne
oui exactement est justement celle de
claude labelle a surpris par sa
modération
après les coups d'éclat que nous avions
entendu à biarritz est ici et il a été
extrêmement modérée ce qui a permis à
monsieur bart de faire luire la
concertation en contrepartie mais je
crois que ce qui est le plus notable
c'est la nouvelle
tactique de monsieur françois mitterrand
sa censure vous l'avez entendu s'adresse
plus aux présidents de la république au
premier ministre et dont les couloirs
christian querré m'a révélé que cette
stratégie serait désormais celle du
parti socialiste tout entier alors là
comme ailleurs monsieur bart a fait
front avec une sorte de patience résigné
puis à monsieur mitterrand qui le
traitait de grand commis il a répliqué
c'est vrai que ma politique économique
est fait sur les orientations du
président de la république mais c'est
une politique économique avec laquelle
je suis entièrement d'accord
et s'il n'en était pas ainsi je ne
resterai pas une seconde de plus dans ma
fonction avoue patrick champagnol le
vote vers quelle heure ont probablement
aux alentours de minuit 1h du mat bien
nous vous retrouverons peut-être avant
cela dans notre dernière édition
depuis le début de ce journal et vous
l'avez constaté en direct l'avion du
chef de l'état s'est posé sur l'aéroport
de brasilia
ainsi commence le voyage officiel au
brésil de monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing
un détail tout de suite il fait très
beau là bas 30 degrés à l'ombre
donc il était 20h de paris 16 heures à
brasilia capitale du brésil
il aura fallu un peu moins de sept
heures et demie y compris l'escale de
dakar à mi-chemin au président de la
république pour aller à bord du concorde
spéciale de paris abrasive
brasilia la capitale presque toute neuve
du brésil ville encore futuriste fondé
de force au milieu de la nature
brésilienne c'était il y a moins de 20
ans le 21 avril 1960
le président de la république qui
accompagne son épouse et plusieurs
ministres messieurs père cité deniau
madame simone veil est accueilli par le
président sortant du brésil général gueï
scène il recevra plus tard le candidat à
la succession à la présidence va
publique brésilienne le général
figueiredo le brésil pays immense
immense par sa superficie qu'un soit la
france par sa population plus de 100
millions d'habitants par ces ressources
qui sont loin d'être toutes exploitées
ainsi on y trouve le tiers des réserves
du monde en minerai de fer sans parler
des métaux plus rares
manganèse mosane iq dont on extrait un
substitut possible de l'uranium il ya
aussi de l'or des diamants et ça c'est
presque bon bref vendre au brésil et
pour les exportateurs pour les
exportateurs français deal sur une
ambition légitime
c'est un client possible tout à fait
seulement voilà donc le fantastique
marché qui s'offrent aux industriels du
monde entier un marché qui tient en
quelques chiffres noël copains le brésil
est actuellement un pays de 120 millions
d'habitants on pense qu'il pourrait en
avoir 300 millions environ en l'an 2000
les économistes parlent déjà une expand
d'une expansion à la japonaise la
superficie du brésil est presque
comparable à celle de l'europe et
certains prophètes annonce même que le
brésil pourrait être les états unis du
21e siècle
et curieusement la france y est très
absente oui elle est en tout cas
beaucoup de retard par rapport à
d'autres pays et pourtant son influence
en particulier sur le plan culturel et
intellectuel était prépondérante au 19e
siècle et même pendant une bonne partie
du 20e siècle
elle s'est fait supplanter par les états
unis après la guerre mondiale et sur le
plan économique
la france s'est également laissé ces
dernières années distancée par
l'allemagne il ya peut-être des raisons
en politique il faut dire que le
président n'est pas un régime qui a très
bonne presse à les démocraties
occidentales donc s est un régime
militaire depuis 14 environ un régime
fort et parce que ce régime est fort
depuis quelques temps il peut se
permettre une certaine libéralisation de
ces institutions
encore qu'il ait quelques bavures
puisqu'on a encore fuis hier un général
mis en prison à brasilia tout ça parce
qu'il avait osé critiquer le principe
des élections et c'est pourquoi je crois
on peut dire que cette visite officielle
du président de la république française
s'inscrit dans le cadre désormais
classique des rapports d'état entre
états qui se situe au dessus des
péripéties politiques v régime et de la
révolution faut ajouter que le brésil
doit beaucoup forcer pour essayer de
rentrer dans l'an 2000 le déséquilibre
pauvres riches est flagrant 46 %
d'inflation il ya deux ans 38% l'année
dernière une dette extérieure qui
dépasse les 32 milliards de dollars faut
dire que le pays s'est lancé dans des
opérations de prestige extrêmement
coûteuse qu'elle abhorre le déménagement
de la capitale de rio à brasilia nous
sommes ici devant le congrès car elle
rassemble l'ensemble des députés
sénateurs et puis il y à aussi la
réalisation de ce rêve qui n'est même
pas à l'échelle humaine
je veux parler de la transamazonienne
huit ans américain de série b ou réalité
d'aujourd'hui une mauvaise piste
d'atterrissage en terre au coeur de
l'amazonie seul contact avec la
civilisation la nôtre celle de 1978
sur quelques mètres carrés tout est là
toutes les légendes celle de nos livres
d'histoire celle des bandes dessinées
une dizaine de cabanes un air de musique
sud-américaine sorti d'on ne sait quel
vieux fono et c'est visage buriné par le
soleil le mauvais alcool et la malaria
ce sont les gars rim pause les
chercheurs d'or avec leur passion leur
folie leur rêve qu'un jour une fois dans
cette poubelle après la boue il ne reste
qu'une fine poussière jaune l'or
en sachant pourtant que d'ici on ne
revient pas il faudrait plusieurs mois
pour traverser tous les pièges de la
forêt amazonienne sans espoir d'en
sortir vivant ou beaucoup trop d'argent
pour faire ce que d'autres font
s'installer haïti touba petite ville du
far west à une heure d'avion dégâts rim
pause où les voitures ont à peine réussi
remplacé les chevaux
ceux là ont compris qu'il était plus
rentable de faire le commerce de l'or
que d'aller le chercher
c'est ici que transit lors récoltés par
les garimpos 500 kg par mois sur le
marché officiel six ans avec le marché
noir
acheté 35 francs le gramme revendu dix
fois plus cher à rio sao paulo à itajuba
se termine laventure du moins celle des
gares impe aux images du passé dans une
amazonie qui se lance aujourd'hui dans
une autre aventure avec les pionniers de
l'an 2000 ici haïti touba passe
maintenant la transamazonienne projet
démesuré du gouvernement brésilien
une route une piste de 4500 km
voilà nous sommes ici au kilomètre 2002
la transamazonienne à 2000 km2 du début
de la route depuis l'océan atlantique
dans moins d'un mois à peu près pas
commencé l'hiver comme nous en europe
sauf qu'ici l'hiver c'est la saison des
pluies et il va pleuvoir pendant presque
sept mois et ici par exemple il n'y aura
plus de route qu'il sera complètement
recouvert par l'eau alors dans sept mois
il pourra recommencer à la refaire
et il ya beaucoup de brésiliens qui
estime que le coût d'entretien de cette
route revient plus cher au gouvernement
que la percée de cette route tous les
ans
alors est-ce que ce projet de prestige
est-ce qu'il faut pas l'abandonner non
je ne pense pas que devra redonner sept
projets parce qu'elle a opérations des
six est une opération c'est une guerre
parce que la première la route de
belinga brasilia a été un très grand
succès au brésil parce qu'elle fait
l'intégration de l'esu d'avec le nord
est maintenant c'est transversal dans un
monde unique ira faire la liaison entre
la région de l'est nord d'ascq et les
far west du brésil jusqu'à la frontière
du pérou il ya un autre problème qui
était soulevée par les écologistes du
monde entier qui prétendent que vous
êtes en train de détruire le dernier
rêve du monde les réserves d'oxygène
s'est arrêté je ne pense pas ça la
traîne amazonie c'est comme une trait de
crayon sur la forêt d'amazonie goût de
crayon qu'il faut élargir chaque année à
la saison des pluies il suffit de
quelques mois la forêt pour recouvrir la
route balayée aussi les critiques sur
les massacres les tribus d'indiens
elles ont existé on ne sait plus très
bien ce qu'elles sont devenues
le gouvernement avait fixé un objectif
coûte que coûte pour la construction de
cette route deux ans et demi maximum les
délais ont été respectés
le deuxième objectif était d'effectuer
un transfert de populations du sud est
vers la transamazonienne quelques
milliers d'hommes sont venus sans
éducation sans bagages on les a
installés dans des villages montée de
toutes pièces
les agro village espèce de communauté ou
la misère se mélange à la misère chaque
famille a reçu une terre de 30 hectares
le gouvernement a avancé une partie des
fonds pour la mise en valeur
jusqu'au jour où l'on s'est aperçu que
cette terre n'était pas cultivables où
l'on s'est aperçu aussi que les hommes
que l'on avait fait venir ici n'était
pas adapté à ce climat ni aux maladies
tropicales
beaucoup sont repartis la
transamazonienne prend aujourd'hui un
autre visage elle permettra d'accéder
dans les dix ou vingt prochaines années
au fantastique ressources de son
sous-sol bauxite or uranium fer les plus
puissants l'ont déjà compris un
milliardaire américain daniel ludwig
propriétaire d'un million et demi d
hectares avec des projets
d'investissement de 300 millions de
dollars
volkswagen qui vient d'acheter 300 mille
hectares et sans doute à chacun des
contrats une amazonie qui perd chaque
jour un peu plus de son mystère ce
voyage officiel monsieur giscard
d'estaing du rajol ai dit tout à l'heure
trois jours l'occasion pour nous de
mieux connaître le brésil qui n'est
connu il est vrai par beaucoup de
français que par l'intermédiaire d'un
certain pelé de manon qu'une bonne
partie de cette édition de 20h vous sera
présentée comme ce soir en direct du
brésil par patrick poivre d'arvor dans
les annales du gangstérisme le massacre
de la saint-valentin à chicago était
jusqu'à présent inégalé
al capone restait le maître du genre
depuis hier soir les truands marseille
ont fait mieux
al capone avait fait assassiner sept de
ses adversaires hier soir neuf personnes
ont été exécutées dans un bar de
marseille est littéralement exécuté une
rafale de pistolet mitrailleur dans le
dos et une balle dans la nuque pour
achever chacun des hommes présents dans
le bar du téléphone à l'établissement
tranquille entre guillemets du quartier
du canet
un petit bar avec ses habitués aux
caennais un quartier populeux de
marseille ici hier soir peu après 20
heures trois tueurs masqués ont
méthodiquement a battu toutes les
personnes présentes d'un seul survivant
véritable miraculé mais il est dans un
état extrêmement grave
il ya donc neuf morts dont le patron du
bar se serait selon la police l'oeuvre
de petits tueur fou qui n'ont rien à
voir avec les gangs d'autres fois ils
ont montré en tout cas une rare
détermination dans la sauvagerie
après un premier tir déjà très précis et
meurtrier ils ont ensuite d'une balle
dans la nuque achevé leurs victimes
c'est de toute l'histoire mondiale du
banditisme
le règlement de compte le plus sanglant
sept morts depuis le début de l'année
auxquels viennent s'ajouter les neuf
victimes du bar du téléphone
les marseillais sont l'addition comme
personne ne pense ici que les amis de
ceux qui ont été abattus resteront
inactifs
la liste est loin d'être close pour la
police le signal du départ que l'on peut
aussi appeler guerre des gangs a été
donné en mars 73 dans un bar de
marseille le tanagra quatre morts trois
blessés graves
depuis cette date le milieu marseillais
divisée n'a cessé de régler ses comptes
l'enjeu l'argent bien sûr grâce aux
raquettes à la prostitution à la drogue
ou au jeu à coups de 11,43 de fusil à
canon scié voire de grenade le bal
macabre se poursuit les loups centre des
bords
malheureusement des innocents se
trouvent parfois sur la trajectoire des
balles au bar du téléphone sur les neuf
personnes a battu 4 était totalement
inconnu des services de police
parmi les autres qui ont été poursuivies
ou condamnées les ces condamnations ces
poursuites concernaient des délits qui
étaient des délits graves
l'un d'eux par exemple a été condamné
pour tentative d'homicide volontaire
les autres pour cambriolage puis enfin
le dos de poser des lignes moins
important aujourd'hui à marseille
la vie continue les belles de nuit ou
l'après midi les belles de jour
exploitent leur mètre carré de trottoir
est peut-être derrière les façades de
certains bars ébauche des projets
d'expéditions punitives
en attendant l'homme de la rue sur cette
canebière préférerait voir sa ville à la
une de l'actualité pour d'autres motifs
restent un problème qui est continuelle
et qui menace toute notre vie qu'a
priori semblerait que ça le rassure
quelque peu désirable la police et le
chômage et jean ils foutent rien pensez
vous marseille est une ville où la
sécurité ne raye pas comme on a l'air de
le faire croire
le suis obligé de dire que nous avons de
commun que chicago que les tours nono
building actuellement la police poursuit
son enquête et c'est un peu une course
de vitesse entre elle et ceux qui vont
vouloir venger leurs compagnons abattu
après les carbone et spirito les guérini
marseille quoi qu'on en dise détient un
triste record dans l'histoire de la
criminalité pas d'armes pour la police
de l'île a déclaré son maire monsieur
pierre mauroy pourtant les policiers
municipaux ont entamé depuis deux jours
une grève du zèle pour réclamer un port
d'armes est aussi la suppression du
gardiennage des bâtiments publics
tunisie peine de mort demandé contre
monsieur habib achour et les autres
anciens membres dirigeants de l'ue gtt
l'union générale des travailleurs
tunisiens dans un réquisitoire
particulièrement dur le procureur de la
république tunisienne a déclaré que les
accusés étaient responsables des émeutes
qui avaient marqué la grève générale en
tunisie au début de l'année
amorcée hier après midi la chute du
dollar s'est accentué aujourd'hui à
paris le dollar est revenu à 4 francs
2,4 francs 33 à 4 francs 28 4 francs 29
et l'or lui a pulvérisé son record mais
en hausse à londres l'once valait 223 $
75 et le lingot à paris s'est vendu à 30
mille francs
350 un quatrième camion spatiale pour sa
lieu de six comme ses prédécesseurs il
porte le nom de progress
il contiendra plus d'une tonne de
matériel les deux cosmonautes kovalenko
et ivan tchesnokov n'auront aucune
difficulté pour jouer les déménageurs de
l'espace depuis trois mois et demi qu'il
tourne c'est leur troisième expérience
cette nouvelle arrivée signifiant du cac
que le séjour des deux classes moloch
risque fort de se prolonger encore assis
longtemps
de combien on ne le sait pas encore et
puis après jean pharand rtl pierre son
président monsieur christian chavanon
qui vient d'être placé en position de
détachement par le gouvernement monsieur
chavanon sera chargé d'une mission
d'étude sur l'enseignement du français à
l'étranger
à la veille de l'ouverture du salon de
l'auto une surprise de taille attendait
ce matin les amateurs de voitures voici
une nouvelle renault 5 elle ne ressemble
pas du tout à celle que vous connaissez
elle est beaucoup plus musclée et
c'était la surprise présenté par le pdg
de la régie renault monsieur vernier
falaise ce matin lors d'une conférence
de presse la nouvelle ère 5 r5 turbo
première application sur la voiture de
monsieur tout le monde de la technique
qui a fait gagner renault 24 heures du
mans et qui anime la formule 1 du
championnat du monde des conducteurs
ce monstre une renault 5 équipée d'un
moteur central turbocompressé 200
chevaux plus de 200 kilomètres heure
cette voiture très très spécial sera
régulièrement engagés dans les
compétitions routière à partir de 1981
400 modèles pourraient être
commercialisés dans le courant de
l'année prochaine
nouveau également mais plus sage une r30
et x boîte 5 vitesses injection 55 mille
francs une concurrente directe de la 604
peugeot bernard vernier payet pdg de la
régie dressait ce matin le bilan des
activités du groupe 7850 voitures
produites par jour dans le monde
un moteur diesel pour bientôt sur les
modèles de haut de gamme et puis après
avoir été annoncé au début de l'année
est mis depuis en sommeil les accords
avec american motors devrait aboutir
vers la fin de l'année
l'implantation américaine de renault
devrait donc commencer dans le courant
1979 bien nous avons un journal un peu
plus long ce soir que d'habitude je vais
juste vous donner les résultats du loto
le tirage est effet cet après midi vous
voyez les résultats 12 21
enfin 8 et 26 avec un numéro
complémentaire le 27
rapidement la météo pour demain temps
généralement ensoleillé malgré quelques
averses sur la corse et des pluies
matinales dans l'est quelques nuages
aussi de la manche aux ardennes par
contre moins de mistral et de tramontane
dans le midi le dernier rendez-vous avec
l'actualité ce soir vers 23h05 23h10 un
journal présenté par avec l'autre qui
est à mes côtés
merci de nous avoir suivis bonne soirée
à tous et à demain soir